welcome back to the 49th ever episode
of the iced coffee hour i'm craig and to
date this podcast has made
55 706.93
oh my god that was great that was
incredible thank you so much craig uh
craig thank you so much for coming on
the podcast gonna be a really fun
episode because i feel like this is one
of the few episodes that we've had
someone on the podcast
who's not on youtube is this the first
one we've done for them
oh my gosh it just might be christine
christine is not on youtube oh but she's
but she's like a public figure yeah
she's on tv this is this is our first
well does it count if my daughter has a
youtube channel she's got i think 100
subscribers
there we go that's pretty good yeah nice
diamonds for kim everybody check her out
nice
i feel like we should probably get this
out of the way but how did you two
meet exactly and and what sparked your
interest so much that you would like to
extend an invitation for him to come on
the plane yeah this is unusual by the
way
usually we reach out to other people to
have on the podcast
and it's us actively thinking oh who
would be great for you know it would be
great to have on oh we haven't had uh
nato brian on an award let's get him on
her yeah so
this came about when i uh posted that i
bought the ford gt
and you sent me an instagram message and
i don't
did i respond to you before was this
like a no
because my my instagram dms get flooded
and i think that sometimes i just sort
by most recent and yours happened to
come up
and you had a few pictures up there
right and so i looked at the pictures i
think i was with jack
at the time and i was telling you dude
look at his collection so you have
basically the same
for gt that i do i i i did
i bought it uh 2005 2006
and it had my vanity plate on it which
is l-e-m-n-l-a-w
that was it yeah so i sent it to you
right away and i said
graeme you're going to love your car i
loved mine here's a picture yeah and you
you were one of you yeah under your name
he got right back to me
and i said oh you like that let me show
you some of the other cars that have
worn this plate
and i i think i flooded your box after
that can we share some of those pictures
on here sure
okay yeah and i remember seeing these
pictures and being like this is
insane the car collection that you that
you have had over the last i don't know
how many years
was incredible i mean this is like a
dream garage that i feel like every
teenager
would want the cars that you now have
but yeah but you sent all these pictures
i was shown jack and then you responded
back with
this is what i do for a living if you if
if you ever want to have me on the
podcast let me know i thought it was
just so interesting because it was so
different
than everyone else that we have on the
on the channel of just like oh yeah i
know i do youtube i'm in personal
finance i'm investing
this for us is such just a different
perspective that i think is so important
to have
but this is a fun episode i think
because one
you're you have a legal background and
you
own the largest lemon law practice
correct
yes i'm a consumer attorney we have the
largest automobile warranty practice
lemon law in the nation for the last 30
plus years
and i also do a lot of uh telephone
consumer protection act cases
uh which involve robocalls and how much
can you collect per cause if fifteen
hundred dollars you can make per phone
call
500 to 1500 per call federal law you can
also make
a lot more than that in certain states
like texas virginia missouri which have
separate state laws
wow could you tell us about that really
quickly so those are the
my auto warranty is expired i can't get
them to stop calling me they're calling
me all the time
i could get them to pay me 500 to 1500.
so right the types of calls we're
talking about there's a couple different
types under the telephone consumer
protection act
the first one is the one that you're
referencing which were called do not
call
cases you put your name on the do not
call registry uh with the fcc
and you have uh the ftc rather and you
have
told them i don't want to get these
calls and
still companies use random dialers
and they just keep calling numbers one
after the next and oftentimes you get a
robocall
since you never gave your consent for
those calls they're unlawful under the
federal law
between 500 and 1500 per call
you're entitled to for each of those
calls now the reason why it's this way
is because you never agreed to those
calls and because these companies are
doing this
thousands of times a day each company
some of them to sell solar panels
automobile warranties
insurance you name it if they can sell
it using a
phone they're trying to do so and
oftentimes you pick up the phone
and then you're asked to wait or you
hear a noise and you're waiting
for somebody to pick up the phone
whether in this country or some other
country
and it's just a process by which they
try to wear you down and keep calling
you until you buy their product
wow how do you actually collect money i
feel like these these businesses are
structured in such a way where it's a
shell company within a shell company and
a trust
and an offshore account and they're
routing phone calls from like you know
different ip addresses how do you
actually
locate who's calling you okay so like
you i do this for a living so we know a
lot of the bad actors
there's always more every day but there
are certainly occasions where we have to
do a lot of investigation
most of those overseas companies that
call you are actually working for a
company in the united states
sometimes they're direct hires and
they're working overseas
sometimes they are subcontracted parties
what they call marketing affiliates
which is a fancy way of saying we're
having them break the law for us
and then the primary company claims well
we didn't make the calls
we're not responsible so that we have to
prove that they are in fact responsible
they knew what this company was doing
or maybe if their contract said they're
not supposed to be doing it
um the lead company understands that the
the parent company is going to tolerate
it because it's going to help the bottom
line
wow why are we receiving so many of
those auto warranty calls right now
because like what you do for a living it
makes money
and if it makes money companies are
going to do it until the cost
of violating the law exceeds the money
that they're making for example the
average warranty company
will make about 5 million a year in
telephone calls wow
so if they have to pay out 500 000 in
violations
they don't love it but they do it
wow i don't even understand like what
are they selling because i'm not i don't
receive any of these calls well
um you should feel fortunate you don't i
mean i get tons of calls from like kelly
blue book who calls me
all the time i have a totally random
number that's not associated with me
at all it's it's just like a burner
phone basically i i receive phone calls
on that number i'm not on any list at
all
what is it like what do they do we want
to let you know your auto warranty
is expiring please press zero to be
connected with and
like that's pretty much it so basically
graham would approach you and
he'd say like hey i got a phone call
from like a robo-caller
trying to take you know money from me
for an auto warranty can you get me
fifteen hundred dollars
is that how it works so much easier than
that it could be a call
or a text do you ever get these crazy
texts
uh matthew mcconaughey says he's not
going to marry her
and then there's a link and you click on
the link and it goes to some company
that's trying to sell you some rewards
product
let me see really quick if i could find
a thing uh let's see renew your warranty
before we close the file yes if you're
interested in renewing your auto
warranty now
please press five now or press nine to
be removed from our list
oh wow see and and i've heard by the way
that
if you pick up then you're on a separate
list of people who actually pick up the
phone is that true
well it's different companies do things
different ways it depends on how the
computer is programmed
generally speaking they will call until
they take you off a list so
you're in there and if you get a recall
you're going to continue to get calls
unless you're removed from the list the
way that happens normally
in our case is when we sue we demand
that the client's phone number is taken
off the list
in some cases we know the company we
don't put that in the release because we
know they're going to call again
and we just file a second claim do you
have to prove that they have
called you multiple times and you've
asked to be removed from the list but
they continue to call you like
how do you delineate between like okay
you can charge 1500
from these people and give it to you
versus no you can't they're not breaking
the law yet
that's a great question so typically
speaking the first calls free or the
first text is free
some companies have adapted to being
sued by only sending one text
but they'll send you one text a variety
of different times in a variety
different
messages and they're hoping you don't
take action
other companies are just looking at the
model and we make five million dollars a
year we pay 500 000
in settlements let's keep doing it until
it's no longer profitable
and from i tell these companies up front
listen i'm a consumer lawyer
and i want to protect my client from
these calls but i understand your
business reason for calling these people
you're making money
understand that like a postage stamp or
or uh
some other feed that a business incurs
is overhead i'm part of the overhead if
you're going to do that
can this is something that a person can
do on their own or is it something where
you
need to hire an attorney to represent
you the answer to that question is a lot
of people are doing this on their own
and they're successful i i know people
who have made hundreds of thousands of
dollars
doing this on their own wow either with
help yeah uh from companies that are
uh providing packages that they sell for
you know forty fifty dollars
to help inform people and equip them
to go after the callers or the texters
and i belong to a number of groups where
we discuss you know
what are you seeing with this company
what are you seeing with that company
i'm dealing with such and such is that a
legitimate person what do you think i
should recover
so we do share that information because
even though these are not my clients
i want to help them get their recoveries
now is this something where somebody can
almost
entrap some of these people in the sense
that you get like a new phone number
and you purposely put your put your
number out there as much as possible and
then receive these calls in
and just be like i've seen you you you
you can you do that there are absolutely
those people out there
there's a lot of successful people at
that wow we try to filter out those
cases coming into our firm
because what we try to do is we try to
help victims
turn something that's really upsetting
them into something that has at least
been worth their while to pursue and to
stop
for people who go out of their way to
create phone numbers i know people have
many phone numbers
so yes there are people who have done
that very very successfully
um small percentage of people the vast
number of people are not those types of
people ah jack you can't do that i know
that was sounding like a good business
side hustle like things you could do on
a weekend is just go get a phone get a
phone number like a google voice number
start making in the calls you know you
don't have to that's the whole point
we're all getting these robocalls right
so if you just make it instead of a
a side hustle if you just make it like a
in my way hustle
you know this is getting in my way yeah
i'm gonna take action i'll do it a
couple times get used to it
every time i get a call i'm gonna go
after these people it will definitely
profit you and it will be legitimate you
don't have to make anything up
to turn along could you like mediate
right because i obviously i'm not an
attorney but what if they call me and i
say like
and i i get into contact with them and i
say look can we mediate and you give me
750
instead of me getting a lawyer and then
we charge you like 1500 or do they never
do that and you always have to utilize a
lawyer to actually like sue them
okay so it's like going to the bar and
asking somebody if you can buy them a
drink
you don't know your answer you're going
to get unless you ask right
you never succeed anytime you don't do
something but if you try you might get
what you want
some people are very successful at
getting reduced recoveries
uh some companies will some companies
won't and um
you never know until you ask it does
happen though and how many what
percentage of these companies are
us-based
the vast majority of them really yeah
the vast majority like
98 wow so let's just run through like a
scenario right so i get a phone call
and it says scam likely and then i
answer it and then it's like a robocolor
like
what do i do from there well there's a
variety of things
there's technologies fortunately on
every cell phone that allow you to
record
screenshots of text let's say or recall
or record
conversations using an app and you might
say well wait a second a lot of states
don't let me do that
you have to get somebody's permission to
record generally speaking not if the
call is coming in to you
because it's an unsolicited sales call
and you're trying to identify the caller
your purpose is legitimate to record
you're like look i've gotten calls from
this company before
i want to find out who they are they
never tell me who they are
and i'm doing this for forensic reasons
to identify the company
because they by the way they will always
deny that they called you if you don't
have proof
always so if you get a call and you send
a letter and you don't have proof a
screenshot
which could be spoofed or a recording
um they're going to just deny it and so
what we can do as lawyers that the
individual can't do
is to forensically trace where that
calls come from right so basically you
get the call
and then you have to send a letter to
the company yes okay so i didn't answer
your question i'll get to it now
yes so if you can identify the company
let's say it's john's warranty company
you say john you know i'd like to to
talk to you about this warranty that
you're calling me about
can you give me more information and
they're really they're experts at not
giving you the information they know
what you're thinking perhaps
so sometimes what you do is you buy the
product
you buy the 600 warranty and i'll tell
you
a way to do that and not get hurt but
let's say you buy that and you're like
wait a second i just i just dropped 600
on this once you buy that warranty
you know who sold it to you it's on your
credit card
now you might say but i don't have the
opportunity to spend all this money on
these calls for people knowing my credit
card information
there are uh apps available one is is
called the cash app
where you can have a zero balance but
still have the card
so when they try to charge the purchase
and it doesn't go through
you still get the information of the
company that tried to charge the card
wow what was that sponsor we did for
that privacy
privacy guys yeah if you haven't already
download
sign up for privacy.com it's an amazing
service
are they sponsoring this but they're
darn they're they're great services i
know they are
like i use them here all the time so
it's actually an amazing this would have
been such a great plug for
that because you're able to create these
these basically one-off numbers
it's a it's a burner it's a basically a
burner debit card and you can create
like
15 of them a month sure and then you
could just cancel it with the click of a
button
right set transaction limits and do all
that that's exactly the type of service
we're talking about wow
it turns the tables on the people who
think that they're
immune from being responsible and when
you turn the tables on them
they pay they know because the last
thing they want
is to shut down the machine that's
making them all these millions of
dollars a year
are these warranties actually legitimate
or are they all just scams that's so i
was wondering like what actually happens
when you buy it
what if it's a great product yeah like
it saves you so much money because it's
usually
auto warranty yes and an answer to your
question
in my experience this is the part of my
practice where i can answer definitively
as an expert
um these warranties really are not that
great okay most of them
they'll say whatever they need to say to
you on the phone to sell you the
warranty but when you
get the information sent to you after
you buy the warranty
it's lots of disclaimers and lots of
limitations
now the good part about it is under
federal law if you're not provided a
copy of what you're buying before the
transaction goes through
none of the limitations are enforceable
so if i sell you a warranty and i've
promised you all these different things
or even if i haven't
but i told you it's a full warranty and
then you pay for it you get the warranty
in the mail
or it's sent to you online and you see
all these limitations
all those limitations are ineffective
because you were not provided the right
to see what the limitations were before
you made the purchase
so what if what if they call gram and
they're like hey uh
you know we want to sell you a warranty
for your car six hundred dollars and
graham's like okay and then he does it
for his ford gt
and then he crashes his ford gt and yeah
warranty that would be an insurance
issue it would be like if the engine
breaks
so what is it what does a warranty even
mean it's actually not a warranty under
federal law
it's really a service contract they call
it a warranty because everybody knows
what a warranty is
very few people know what a service
contract is under the law service
contract
is like toilet paper compared to the
finest egyptian thread towel of a
warranty
there's an analogy again so i love this
we gotta get better at these
announcements i know yeah
so do i agree with my wife so
um so basically service contracts are
not what people want to buy
usually subprime lenders and subprime
buyers
are the ones who are most victimized by
these service contracts because they
really believe they're buying
insurance they're buying some type of
protection and the vast majority
of cases when they have a claim it's a
big game you know
allegedly you're calling the
administrator the warranty to have your
claim covered
all the administrators doing is calling
back the dealership that sold you the
warranty or the company that sold you
the warranty
and asking them what they want you to do
and then they trickle the communication
back to you and say oh i'm sorry it's
been denied but
they'll pay you something and then the
person takes whatever's offered
so it's a big scam wow it's pretty much
like a vast majority of them are just
scams
i use the word scam to say that what you
think you're buying and what you're
actually sold are two different things
so
in that definition yeah that's what i'm
going to say do they tell you something
yeah very a lawyer think this
yeah yeah you know you have a lot of
followers people are watching this
and i don't want them to get the wrong
impressions i understand yeah so they
are selling you something what they're
selling you
you don't know until you get the the
terms has ever been thought about doing
like a class action getting everyone
together
like i've seen those um i i can never
pronounce this
mesothelioma i can't i could never
mesothelioma yes
first classes right first has there ever
been
somebody who would do something like
this for a commercial saying if you've
received these
you know robocalls please call us we
want to know your information
with mesothelioma there's actually i
almost did it myself yeah there's
there's a fund
that was created many many years ago by
the courts by which claimants who meet
certain standards can
get a recovery from the fund that's been
established for these types of cases
these are really based upon pursuing
claims thinking that the company you're
suing is going to have the resources to
pay the result
so recently there was a case that was
finally upheld
um at the highest level that involved
directv
that had made i think it was something
like 750 million dollars worth of
penalties in the tcpa they were sued for
a class action they were trying to avoid
liability they're trying to blame the
insurance company they're trying to do a
bunch of different things
and ultimately they said hey this is
just too much for the harm that we
caused
the statute is unconstitutional and the
court said no
you know you've done this you'll pay now
directv has the money
they're owned by at t now they sure do
but
the average company will have far more
liability
dollars at stake than they have
resources to pay
what they often do i know one company i
just took a 100 000
default judgment against one of these
warranty companies last week i'll send
you a copy
uh where the company all they do is they
change names of the company and they go
back into business under a different
name
this particular company is owned by
somebody who has a very
checkered history uh criminal history of
people around this person
and there's a lot of question marks
about this person but it's a big money
maker
yeah who starts these up people who want
to make money and don't want to do it
the way that
perhaps you want to do it the way i want
to do it wow they want to get as much as
they can
spend as little as possible and not let
anything get in their way unless
somebody stops them
interesting so you tell me if i receive
a phone call
asking for an auto warranty all i have
to do is
call you and then you can bring me
money well if you had you been listening
to me and my great analogies you would
have known
that what i said is you have to make a
recording of these calls um
right right document these calls i'm not
trying to chastise you i'm just trying
to
be clear like it's not as easy as all
that right if you have documentation or
call us and we'll tell you what we need
from you
and and we've had clients who we've sent
back to get this information
and they've contacted us again a month
or two later and gotten us exactly what
we needed
um yes the answer is yes we tell people
if you're going to get a a text message
please
before that message expires hit the
record button on your screen if it's an
iphone for example or use an android app
there's
there's a couple of them out there
record yourself pressing the button on
that link
see where it goes to it's going to be a
different company it's going to be a
different entity scroll down to the
bottom slowly
and show me the name of the company at
the bottom of that message
then yes the answer is yes i can help
you i wish
i'm going to get one of these calls
during the podcast i would love that
that would make the episode if if
just i'm putting it out in the universe
right now if we could receive a call
like that
during this episode i will be so happy
hey
the statute really does things more than
just give people money that they they
think that they're they're getting
something for nothing
i've had clients who've received so many
of these calls and
of course these are the extreme cases
but i've had a client uh who
actually went off of government
assistance
got a new house and got a ramp because
they were handicapped got a ramp
to their house because i got them so
much money
wow i hope that's not one now but yes it
does happen and for those stories you
really are so happy because
their lives are different than what
yours is and what mine is and you know
you've made a difference
it really is a nice thing to be able to
take such a horrible
um set of circumstances being bombarded
by collection calls for a medical
problem that wasn't your fault
and be able to turn that all around and
put somebody into their own position of
owning their house
that's accessible for them that they
don't know anybody any money for they're
not going to be on the government
assistance anymore
and they're moving forward with their
life that's incredible it really was a
great story for us and we have a couple
of them like that
um a lot of these cases i will say a lot
of these cases do arise from medical
debt
and so people who get themselves in a
situation either because
they had a medical problem or maybe an
employment problem they lost their job
they can't pay their bills anymore
they're getting these calls they've told
the company to stop calling
and they continue to call them got it
how did you get involved
in this so like i said earlier i had a
saline mustang that i bought and
probably paid every penny that i should
have or more
to buy this car as my first new vehicle
which year was it it was 1989.
is that the one with the bar the the
roll cage bar over the top
oh my sticker on the side yeah yeah i
love those it was a great car and uh
i was in law school and ford had a paint
process back then where they
decided to skip the primer to save money
and they thought this would be great
yeah you could save all this money
saline jesus
okay the stickers came off the car the
paint came off the car i had them
repainted they were glad to do it fine
the second time that they returned that
they didn't fix it properly and the
paint was still coming off i reached out
and i said you need to buy this car back
they said up this is a lease vehicle
pennsylvania doesn't cover leases and
anyway we've already tried to fix it
forget about it
so i got the name of the person i was
dealing with i will only say his first
name was drew
he's probably watching because he's
retired now and
um hey drew ice drew make sure to hit
the like button if you haven't done that
already
and get your free stock down below in
the description it's worth all the way
up to 50
you may as well do it it's free money
there you go joe i gave you something
back
savage you know we got to do the other
glasses
[Laughter]
so so i told drew i thought you were
tired here's my name
here's i'm in law school you're going to
remember my name in the future
and i graduated law school i opened my
own practice shortly thereafter
and i started taking lemon law cases and
drew was somebody i have deposed
probably a hundred times over the years
no way a lot to drew
i i thank you drew took care of me i
took care of drew but it was never
voluntarily
uh what is depose the pose means i took
his his deposition under his foreign
testimony about oh wow
so if a client had a car problem yeah we
the manufacturer would appoint an expert
or a representative to talk about it
and to tell you why it's not a lemon and
because i'm a car guy
i've worked as a mechanic i've been a
car guy my whole life like you i knew
when somebody was telling me something
that wasn't true and i could dissect it
and turn it around on them
which was pretty novel back then because
most lawyers are not car people
so we were able to call them out on
their answers
and win case as a matter of fact it took
the better part of 10 years
before i lost my first lemon low case
but um
that's how it all started and because
the law allows the manufacturer forces
the manufacturer to pay attorney's fees
my marketing concept everybody's got a
marketing concept was
hey consumer if i can't help you i'm not
going to get paid
but if i can help you you're going to
get your money back you're not going to
pay me anything
and so i wrote a radio advertisement
shortly thereafter on a sports radio
station in philadelphia
and i listened to that first
advertisement air with my partner
bob bob silverman and um
before the advertisement ended this is
back in the 19 early 1990s
we got our first call before the ad
ended
and we had 40 cases after the first
month wow
we had a lot more cases after six months
and we very quickly became the largest
in the united states
i at the inception of the internet i
bought lemonlaw.com
and 1-800 lemon law is our phone number
wow and we have been
you know i guess i'm two to my own horn
um we have been the largest lemon law
practice in the country ever since i
feel like we should also explain lemon
law
yeah could you so a lemon law is
basically you bought
a car and the car has a warranty we've
had that word before
and the car is not repaired under
warranty within a reasonable period of
time
every state has a lemon law some are
better than others generally speaking
if the manufacturer through its
authorized dealership has not resolved
the problems
within a certain period of time or
certain number of repair attempts or
even if the parts are on order
and haven't yet arrived the clock ticks
against the manufacturer
and you can assert a claim either for a
full refund
minus a small offset for use or you can
ask for a new car your choice and and
get a brand new car
um and so what we can do is help people
get what they paid for that's what it's
all about
i bought this great car with this great
warranty in some cases like
some of these career manufacturers are
offering 10-year warranties and in year
eight they're getting a claim because
they've consistently had these problems
with the car
and the manufacturer said hey this is an
eight-year-old car we're not paying any
legal claim
and we respond with yeah but you issued
a 10-year warranty and all these claims
have been covered under warranty
you haven't fixed this car throughout
that whole period of time
we've got to client a new car or a
refund that's incredible
my initial understanding of lemon law
was that if you have the same issue
three times or it's been if the car has
been in the service shop
for so many days then it qualifies is
there a rule of thumb like that
so your your reading is correct however
i want to be very clear on this
it's not the same problem it's the same
complaint dealers and manufacturers are
trained to write repair invoices
to avoid lemon law liability they might
call it something different each time
you bring it in
and yet you've complained of the same
problem so the repair invoice may not
bear a resemblance to what you've
actually told them
and they're trying to avoid the
liability so i tell people if you said
my car doesn't shift right
three times and one time they write test
drive car
car operating the specifications second
one uh test drive car they all operate
that way
third one uh car shifted normally
it's all the same complaint what the
dealer does to address the problem is
what the warranty is providing you the
right to have done
so if they choose not to do anything
other than test drive the car that's on
the dealer and the manufacturer
they could have put the car on the lift
they could have pulled parts apart they
could have investigated it
because you have the right to it under
the warranty but they don't because the
monetary compensation for a dealership
is not there unless they find the
problem if they can't find the problem
in a certain period of time they're not
going to get paid
what do you think the dealer is going to
do or they know that a car has
a problem that's common to all these
vehicles or most of them and there's no
fix
so they'll send you on your way saying
there's nothing wrong with your car or
they're all operating the same way or
the manufacturer is aware of the problem
how does that resolve your problem
the law steps in and says no you can't
you can't
respond that way to people they paid for
something you issued a warranty
you failed give them a new car or refund
their choice and you have to pay
attorney's fees manufacturer because
you're not really stepping up for these
people what made you
so uniquely successful above all other
lemon law
practices well like you and like graham
i love what i do i could talk cars all
day long
um i i usually do to a fault and
much to my family's uh dismay
i love cars anything with an engine
mostly cars motorcycles
and so when you have a passion for
something and you've heard this before
when you have a passion for something
whether it be real estate or cars or
something else
it's really not work if you somebody
presents you with a
a rubik's cube problem and says can you
can you fix this
and you love doing it there's an analogy
by the way
so you do them take note of this
so that's that's what it is i just love
what i do and and so does my partner
he's he's fantastic at it
and and so as our staff our entire staff
we have about 50 people working for us
we cover about 48 states the united
states and uh that's what we'd love to
do we love to tell the manufacturers why
they're wrong
and we love to explain it to the judges
how did you get into law in the first
place
did you always know you wanted to be a
lawyer absolutely not did you always
know you wanted to be a youtuber no
no but you fell into it you love it
right so um you could probably see it in
my eyes now you're getting me started
yeah
um basically it started with my my
father mother who felt it
uh i was really good at presenting
myself and really bad accepting no for
an answer much like you i'm sure
and um they said you really should go to
law school and it never
hit my radar i wanted to go to wall
street i wanted to to do something long
financial minds
this is the mid 1980s so a decision had
to be made and
my parents said listen go to law school
don't practice if you don't want to it's
good to have
graduated law school and have that on
your resume wherever you go whatever you
do
so i did and i had been married
previously
my wife at the time had gotten pregnant
around the time i was graduating law
school and so guess what
i was not going to be a working lawyer i
had to pay some bills and i found lemon
law
through my experience in law school and
i thought nobody's doing this
there was no internet by the way for you
for you to there actually was a time
before internet
and the world was a crazy place yeah
listen if we wanted to watch a movie you
had to go down to the store
blockbuster yes yes yes and that was
that was in the advanced times that's
when
it was easy to do right something i
haven't mentioned you i actually wrote
the nation's first computer lemon law
bill in 1999.
and microsoft came in and killed it in
our pennsylvania
house of representatives what were you
trying to accomplish like a computer has
an issue
it's not fixed they're taking too long
they give you another computer there was
a company back then called gateway i
don't know if you remember it
yes we used to have a one of those
gateway could be we had a big thing on
the floor and then the big
you know computer they were very
successful very quickly remember that
they were primarily competitors with
dell
and compact right and although dell had
one too
gateway had an arbitration provision in
their agreements for with consumers
that was so burdensome and so onerous as
to what you had to do to get
relief from the company if you weren't
happy with them fixing your computer
that i decided to write a bill
for the house of representatives in
pennsylvania that forced them to do
better than what their arbitration
procedures forced consumers to do
you had to go to a certain place i think
it was illinois to file a claim
it didn't matter where you were from you
had to file it in illinois appear in
illinois pay 2 500
for the right to have your claim heard
you couldn't file in court it was an
arbitration provision
which is one of the reasons why
attorneys hate arbitration provisions uh
plaintiff slurs
and that's why it was written it got
introduced microsoft appeared with some
other companies and
squashed it they spent way too much
money they knew what was going to happen
if this first law got passed but
at the time on the west coast there were
companies there was a cable show called
silicon
spin on tech tv and john devorak who is
a computer world
uh
reporter he was the host of the show and
he got wind of what i had introduced
and he started inviting me out monthly
as the expert on law and computers
this is you know brand new stuff at the
time nobody really had done it
so i had been on that show probably 10
or 15 times before it finally went off
the air
we just couldn't get that computer lemon
law off the ground fortunately there are
other laws federal laws the magnus moss
warranty act for warranties
which we use with lemon law which you
can use for any product over twenty five
and you can enforce warranties that way
through lawsuits
under federal law that's incredible
where are you investing all of this
money as you're making it well
up until about 10 years ago in a divorce
that changed things but uh in the last
10 or 12 years
um i am like you i'm a big advocate of
tech
and i try to seek out things that i
really love and invest in them
i've been a huge supporter and a
stockholder of well not huge for them
huge for me
in tesla and apple which my my two
biggies that i love okay
um i feel that what elon has done with
the company
and listen we we sue tesla every now and
then so you know for me to invest that's
right
i believe in that company okay they're
not a bad company
they're a little new to the game but um
they're not really a car company they're
a tech company
so uh just fascinated with the whole
idea
taking what is impossible and what
people tell you you can't do which is
what i
faced for many years um and turning it
into something that has value to people
and revolutionizing the world which is
what tesla's done
when did you start investing in tesla
2013 or 14 i guess it was no
so like right after they went public yes
yes i bought a little bit and i wasn't
sure and then i got one of their cars i
got the model s the p90d
yeah and loved the car but more
um then in 2017 i
i was a little concerned was going back
and forth quite a bit so i divested
myself of it for a time
then i got back in about three months
later and i've held on to it since
how's that been for you i'm not
complaining
jack wants to know what what your
percentage gain is i could already tell
and jack is going to tell you about his
dogecoin experience well i think
dogecoin probably did better for you
a lot better yeah yeah but who would you
rather have in the long term
dogecoin no i'm getting tesla watch
dogecoin outperform though we could look
back at this in five years
maybe dogecoin is like ten dollars and
tesla's like fifteen hundred
i'm like eight thousand percent in like
six months
that is amazing and those stories happen
all the time it's a question of
identifying which ones right would you
sell
would you if you're up 8 000 in dogecoin
would you sell it
well at my age i'm not your age so if
it's putting me in a position where
life is going to change uh by selling it
i probably would consider selling it
but i'm not in that position right now
where i i feel that i'm ready to retire
that i want to retire
so to me it's just having confidence in
the company and and watching what they
do and watching how they perform they're
still
on paper probably six years ahead of
everybody else from what i'm reading
and when you're that much ahead in an
emerging technology that people are have
accepted
and and are moving forward with i'm sure
some cars might drive different people
prefer that
but overall what the company has done is
tremendous and to convert it to
roof uh installations and to sell the
energy back
to the grid and to deliver cable and
internet
and spacex and on and on it goes who
knows if
uh boring company is going to be
successful but you never bet against
elon yeah
i hope it is they're coming out with
that loop here in vegas
right have you seen that i've heard
about it i don't know much about it you
gotta watch that they have like a
two-minute commercial it's like a like a
new segment
where they're starting at the las vegas
convention center and basically
creating this whole loop around the las
vegas strip where you could get in your
car right now somebody's driving the car
but you'll get in the car like a taxi it
goes underground
right and you would have this 20-minute
drive with traffic that's done in like
two minutes
right i heard about in california the
way that tesla was going to do it
is primarily offered to tesla owners
first where you would drive your tesla
into this tube and
it would take you wherever you were
supposed to go but if they open it up to
other cars i can see why that would be
really really successful right
yeah i was disappointed so they tried
that
uh they tried the loop initially in the
boring company in hawthorne
and then he wanted permission from the
city of los angeles to put it underneath
the 405 freeway starting in culver city
i was so excited because where this loop
would start was like
two minutes away from a house that i own
right there and i was so excited that
like wow
my place is going to be right in the
middle of like where all this is going
los angeles shut it down they did not
want him going underneath the 405
freeway
and that would have been huge i mean
this was like the part of los angeles
and throw up one of these
one of these clips here if you type in
405 freeway traffic like thanksgiving
you'll see this whole thing it's a sea
of just red from all the tail lights
he wanted to go underneath that and
create this this just
incredible tunnel that would save
everybody probably an hour
and they said no the great thing about
tesla is they have
they're in a position that most
innovators throughout history are not
and that is
innovators are usually opposed by the
establishment almost always and they
don't have the resources to fight
if elon wants to make an issue of
something he's so
uh ingrained himself in our culture and
in his finances in his capital
that uh he could he could change mind if
he wanted to what do you think about
tesla investing in bitcoin i thought it
was genius actually i watched your video
on that a few months ago
um what it's done is two things first of
all it's legitimized
something which a lot of people have
such as myself has you know
been interested in but kind of stayed
away from because i don't understand it
as well as i need to
to make a significant splash in it i'm
not really
uh you know i really concern myself with
thousand and two thousand dollar
investment so i like
if i was going to do it i would do it
significantly and i don't know enough
i want to do it i will do it um but what
elon did was basically legitimize the
concept
and by putting tesla in it what he said
is we are so vested in it for ourselves
and for the future
that everybody who likes tesla is
probably going to like the idea too
because they tend to do what elon wants
so i thought it was genius and sure
enough it went up right away didn't yeah
yeah i would almost recommend almost not
i don't want to say i would recommend
everybody
but i see the potential in having like
one two three percent of a portfolio in
bitcoin
so far i've had a fantastic experience
of that now obviously it's gonna go down
at some point
and then maybe it doesn't look so good
but i don't know i
i am always willing to take the risk for
one to two percent
that it turns out huge and even if i
lose two percent so be it but
i'd rather be in it than out of it at
this point i actually agree i saw your
video a couple i guess it was a month or
so ago right now
and i you you really what i like about
your videos and what i like about
your your content is that it gets me
thinking and looking at the next
level that i need to investigate to
consider what you've come up with and
i agree with you certainly every
portfolio needs diversification and what
could be more diverse than something as
high-risk high-reward as that i also
though
however at least historically have been
um concerned about making sure that i
don't make a foolish investment
and so i've come around to the idea i
just have to decide
where i want to put it yeah the one
guest who i most identify with tell me
it's me kevin
i wish i wish it was you okay um what i
what i really
identify with is james from stradman
yeah because he loves what he does
and he's a nicer guy than i'll ever be
but he loves what he does
and he's incredibly successful because
his love shines through on everything
that he does in his videos
that's somewhat akin to what i feel
about lemon law and my other consumer
practices which is
i've always defended the little guy i
always fight for the underdog it gives
me great satisfaction
to say to a company that tells me you
know we're not going to do this or we're
not going to honor that
to force them to yeah and and i think
that when you love something it comes
across
it comes through it certainly does with
stradman it certainly does with you i
mean
your videos are always produced and
thanks and detailed in a way that
you get so much content in such a short
period of time that if you
finish watching the video and move on to
the next round thinking about what
really happened or writing something
down
you're not giving it the credit it's due
because it really
can be life-changing to adjust yourself
as a matter of fact where i really
started enjoying your videos
my son was graduating law school a
couple of years ago and i sent him a
link to one of your videos i said
this is a guy who's not that much older
than you that i want you to pay
attention to because he's got the right
ideas
and instead of buying the biggest the
best the fanciest the
you know the most flashy think about
that four dollar cup of coffee being
you know 600 in a few years that you're
giving up by having that cup of coffee
yeah
and he has he's done that and uh i think
that's what you really do for a lot of
younger people is that you
provide them a way to have accessible
information and a different thought
process than what
the instagram world currently wants
people to think what would your
advice be for me i'm curious um well i
know you enjoy
life um and i know that you enjoy life a
lot and the ford gt certainly i think
is you're you're toeing the water on
something that you really enjoy and
you're allowing yourself
perhaps reluctantly allowing yourself
for yourself
there are so many opportunities uh with
cars where you can do something
similar own something and pay virtually
nothing for it because when you're done
with it it
can sell for a significant amount of
what you've paid if not more
your car a ferrari 812 super fast
something like that
where the investment is similar the joy
you can have for it is great you don't
have to write it off you don't have to
do anything with it
but when you sell it it's going to cost
you less money
than it would to own you know a brand
new
uh small sport utility vehicle that has
heavy depreciation
why not if you're a car person why not
do that more if that's what gives you
pleasure right
so that would be my my first piece of
advice the other one is how old are you
now graham 30.
okay i'm 57.
literally like that you're gonna be my
age
and you think you're gonna laugh at it
right now i believe it it happened i
believe it yeah
whatever life has in store for you
you're going to snap your fingers you're
going to be my age
you'll be too old for some things and
not ready for others
and you want to make sure that you've
enjoyed life to the fullest
and whatever that means for you do it
now because you don't know what's going
to happen in the future you don't know
who's going to be around you
you don't know what life's going to
present to you if you love cars
make it a bigger part of your life give
yourself that um
time to yourself because it will charge
up what you do behind the camera
and in front of the camera yeah i think
that was the aquarium for me
that was something that i've wanted to
do for like 15 years set up an aquarium
like that
if that's the pleasure that you get from
it absolutely i mean you have the
resources of course
to do whatever you want to do whether
it's climb mount everest or get a fish
tank you know
whatever it is you'd like to do but do
it like my in my life i've
gotten my black belt in martial arts as
a challenge i've become a deep-sea diver
as a challenge scuba diver
i've jumped out of airplanes as a
challenge
got my pilot's license i think the
challenges are so important because
you've achieved a level of success
where if you don't keep your edge and
you don't always have something out
there that's challenging you
in a different way you may find yourself
becoming stale you may find yourself
looking at it as a job
when really it's not a job it's your
passion it's just you're doing it every
day you need something to
kind of break it up a little bit yeah
that's been challenging for me to keep
up the same schedule
and uh and not feel like i'm falling
behind on that
especially with the youtube algorithm i
feel like it really rewards consistency
and like putting out more content
even last night we had we had a uh guys
night where we went to the casino
jack won some money i won some money
alex once that was the first night that
we've really gone out
at least for me like three weeks four
weeks and how did it feel
it was fun it was fun but i was ready to
get back and be like you know
getting early more early nights like
midnight getting early nights and then
you know start today okay so you did
that last night
you're at it again earlier today to my
point it kind of cleanses your soul a
little bit gets you back to what you
like
with a fresh light you're not looking at
it as a you know lifting heavy weight
you're looking at it as something i'm
ready for i can do this it should be fun
from the heart i can tell you i really
identify with what you're doing on this
channel
and your other channels i so admire you
for what you're doing
at such a young age um i know you've had
big people
on big guests and small guests and other
guests
keep doing what you're doing you're on
the right track i i'm i'm really happy
to have met you
and i'm really excited and thankful that
you've invited me on of course
um to that end i actually uh have
something for you today oh yes
and i don't know where it is oh you know
what i left it in the kitchen let me
grab it
wow that's so neat
around the world in a ford gt almost and
then ford gt the complete owner's
experience this is
this is perfect thank you so much my
pleasure wow
oh i love this that's really cool yeah
oh gosh but yeah you have to take it to
heart if you're gonna travel with the
ford gt
make it part of your life pick a place
and go there wow
and don't be afraid about the car
getting damaged or
you know flecks of paint coming off just
enjoy the car that's hard for me to do
i am so careful with that thing like
every little bit and i have yet to drive
it by the way okay so
second piece of advice i've not driven
it yeah well that's probably not a bad
thing sometimes but
yeah piece of advice i've had so many
cars that's not a brag that's a
statement
and the reason i'm telling you that is
because at the end of the day unless
it's truly
a museum piece which i've had use them
they run better when you use them they
give you more pleasure when you use them
and they can always be repaired if
there's a problem you're going to get
such a small percentage of joy out of it
by letting it sit
compared to what you're going to get by
enjoying it yeah
and and you've got the car you've got a
great investment there and it's going to
be fun to drive
use it it's an easy car to drive long
distance too it's not a bad car for that
i was going to take it out tomorrow
morning there you go so that'll be my
first time driving it
so with that said you guys thank you so
much for watching i really appreciate
it thank you so much for coming on this
is a fun episode so if you guys
like this episode want to see more like
it make sure to destroy the like button
subscribe we'll link to your information
down below in the description if you
want that
and make sure by the way take your free
stock down below in the description
public is going to give you a free stock
of your choice all the way up to 50
you may as well do that it's free money
takes you like two minutes and i'm
posting all my stocks on there so
if you want to be a part of it link down
below thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time
welcome back to the 49th ever episode of
the iced coffee hour okay